tenemos el sistema de ecuaciones que
igual a 4x 17.5 y 2x igual a 6.5 y
tenemos que resolver este sistema para x
y es decir buscamos x y que cumplan
ambas ecuaciones para esto pensemos en
lo siguiente en la ecuación de arriba la
aie ya está despejada déjame reescribir
esta ecuación lo voy a hacer en rosa
e igual a 4 x menos 17.5 así es que esta
primera actuación está estableciendo la
restricción de que ya tiene que ser
igual a 4x 17.5 de acuerdo a la segunda
ecuación si el valor de yeles sumamos 2x
debemos obtener 6.5 la ye de aquí tiene
que cumplir con la restricción de la
primera ecuación tiene que cumplir con
la restricción de que debe ser igual a 4
veces el valor de x menos 17.5 lo que
podemos ser entonces es sustituir el
valor de g de esta primera actuación en
la segunda ecuación déjame precisar lo
que voy a hacer la segunda ecuación es
de más 2 x es igual a 6.5 sabemos que ya
tiene que ser igual a esto que tenemos
aquí 4x menos 10 y 7-5
tomemos entonces 4x menos 17.5 y vamos a
sustituir este valor de aquí y así es
que si reemplazamos esa y por 4x 17.5
que es lo que se establece en la primera
ecuación obtenemos entonces
4 x menos 17.5
+ 2x igual a 6.5 ahora ya tenemos una
ecuación lineal en una sola variable
vamos a despejar x tenemos aquí 4x y 2x
que vamos a sumar 4 x + 2 x nos da 6 x
- 17.5 y esto es igual a 6.5 ahora vamos
a deshacernos de este 17.5 sumando 17.5
a ambos lados de la ecuación sumamos
17.5 del lado izquierdo y sumamos 17.5
del lado derecho que tenemos entonces
tenemos que 6x estos términos se van y
esto es igual a 6.5 17.5 veamos 617 es
23 y puntos 5.5 es 1 esto es igual a 24
dividiendo ahora entre 6 ambos lados de
la ecuación
esto se cancelan y nos queda que x es
igual a 24 en 364 ya hemos calculado el
valor de x de la pareja xy que cumple
con estas ecuaciones vamos a calcular
ahora el valor de g y podemos hacer esto
al sustituir este valor de x en alguna
de las dos ecuaciones en cualquier las
dos vamos a obtener el mismo valor
usemos esta de arriba suponiendo que x
es igual a 4 entonces esta ecuación
resulta en de igual a 4 por el valor de
x que hemos obtenido que es 4 menos 17.5
menos 17.5 esto es igual a 4 por 4 16
menos 17.5 lo cual es igual a menos 1.5
este es el valor de y así la solución a
este sistema de ecuaciones es x igual a
4 igual a menos 1.5 esta solución
funciona para las dos ecuaciones por
supuesto en la de arriba 4x4 es 16 menos
7.5 obtenemos el valor de ye de menos
1.5
también funciona para la ecuación de
abajo chequemos esto tenemos que menos
1.5 más 2 veces el valor de x + 2 x 4 y
esto cuánto nos da menos 1.5 + 8 esto es
6.5 así es que estos valores de xy se
cumplen con ambas ecuaciones